a thermometer in a science lab displays
the temperature in both Celsius and
Fahrenheit if the mercury in the
thermometer rate rises to 56 degrees
Fahrenheit what is the corresponding
Celsius temperature so right from the
get-go there is a formula that if you
get have the Celsius temperature it'll
give you the Fahrenheit if you have the
Fahrenheit it'll give you the Celsius
now I have a bad memory so I always have
to pseudo derive it and maybe in future
videos we'll totally derive it once we
get a little bit more algebra if you
just know the boiling and freezing
points in both scales you should be able
to figure out the relationship between
the two now the way I always remember it
is that there's a relationship of five
ninths or nine fifths between the two
and then you have to add or subtract 32
and what way I think about it is Celsius
the the the Fahrenheit number is always
going to be larger so if you start with
or at least while we are in kind of our
normal everyday living scales we know
when water is in its liquid form and all
of that so if you start with a Celsius I
say oh I have to make it bigger so I
have to say okay I'm gonna multiply that
by 9/5 that will make it bigger and then
I'm going to add 32 to it and the reason
why I know to add 32 is because when
Celsius is zero zero times nine fifths
is still zero and we know when Celsius
is zero Fahrenheit is going to be 32 so
I know I have to add 32 to it so at
least my gut is telling me that the
formula is nine fifths times Celsius
times the Celsius degrees plus 32 and
you can verify that this works for the
boiling point this definitely works for
the freezing point when Celsius is zero
this is going to be zero you add 32
that's going to be Fahrenheit when
Celsius is 109 fifths times 100 is 180
plus 32 is 212 so this works now what
they've given us is the Fahrenheit
they've given us the Fahrenheit
temperature and we need to get the
Celsius temperature now I could just put
the 56 in here and solve for C and that
will completely work or I could solve
for C using this so I have the equation
for Celsius in terms of Fahrenheit
either way so let's let's do it the
second way so we have the second
equation so if we subtract 32 from both
sides of this equation so if we subtract
32 subtract 32 from both sides of this
equation we get Fahrenheit minus 32
is equal to 9/5 times Celsius now to
solve for Celsius we can multiply both
sides of this equation times five ninths
multiply both sides of this equation
times five ninths five over nine and so
we will get nine cancels with nine five
cancels with five that was the whole
point behind multiplying by the
reciprocal and so we are left with we
are left with remember this five ninths
is going to be times this whole left
side we are left with Celsius Celsius is
equal to 5/9 times Fahrenheit minus
thirty-two so we just rearrange this
equation up here to get this equation
down here and what when I didn't derive
the equation this video I just kind of
pseudo remembered it and make sure I got
the equation right but you can derive it
if you just remember that when you get
it's essentially if you know how to find
the equation of a line you say you say
well when Celsius if you use the x
coordinate of Celsius when Celsius is
zero Fahrenheit is sorry when X when
Celsius is zero Fahrenheit is 32 and and
when Celsius is 100 Fahrenheit is 212
and find the equation of the line
between these two points don't worry
about it if you don't know that all you
need to know for this problem is this
right here
but if you know how to solve the
equation for the line you would come up
with this answer right here and you
wouldn't have to memorize it now now
that we've actually gotten this far
let's just put in 56 degrees for the
Fahrenheit temperature and figure out
what the Celsius temperature is so if we
put 56 in there we're going to have five
ninths times 56 times 56 minus 32 is
equal to the Celsius temperature so 56
minus 32 let me continue it up here let
me
well just so we get it looks a little
bit more it looks a little bit more than
we're going in this general direction 56
minus 30 is 26 minus 2 is 24 so this is
going to be 24 so it's going to be five
ninths five ninths times 24 this right
here that right there is 24 five ninths
times 24 is going to be equal to
and let's see if we can simplify this at
all
so 24 is so this is the same thing as
five times 24 over nine 24 is divisible
by three you divide it by 3 you get 8 9
divided by 3 is 3 so 5 times 8 is equal
to 40 over 3 Celsius degrees Celsius now
if we want to write this as a mixed
number three goes into 40 13 times right
13 times and you have a remainder of 1
so it's 13 and 1/3 and we can even check
that 3 times 13 is 39 plus 1 is 40 and
if this wasn't obvious to you you could
actually just take 3 into 44 3 goes into
4 one time 1 times 3 is 3 subtract you
get 1 bring down that 0 3 goes into 10
three times 3 times 3 is 9 you subtract
you get a remainder of 1 so it's 3 and
1/3 so this is 13 and 1/3 degrees
Celsius so if it's 56 degrees outside in
Fahrenheit it's 13 and 1/3 degrees in
Celsius